i'm ahmed and i'm here to tell you a
little bit about self-service
if you've heard any about narrator or
the activity scheme in the past it's a
very strongly opinionated way of doing
data and i'm here to tell you how i got
there and how it actually works so
hopefully we'll do that in 10 minutes
so
most data as we know kind of follows
this kind of process where we start with
a bunch of requests coming in some
business stakeholder has questions we
bring that data into our data warehouse
we do a bunch of data preparation or we
take that data or write a lot of sql
queries
often it's some star schema formats to
create some dimensions create some facts
and then we put that in the dashboarding
tool and then we let people visualize it
and i've been doing this thing for a
while and i'm going to just go through
one of the la the company before our
narrator my journey there
so
the first thing we did at wework uh in
2015 was we actually built this first
system we said great we were getting 20
questions the company was pretty small
uh we used our postgres as the warehouse
and we were using a cron scheduler for
our sql queries because why not and then
we had chardio and it was okay but we
spent a lot of time using cron and this
process took forever so of course
postgres and cron are terrible so let's
switch to the next hottest tool that was
available so we were like great now we
have redshift and a warehouse yay and we
were using luigi which was very popular
by spotify and we shrunk time but we
kept getting way more questions
so we're like
you know what the problem is is that
luigi sucks let's switch to airflow so
we switched to airflow and we bought
tableau we're like yeah tableau is
going to solve all my problems bi they
sold me
but we kept getting more questions
and we're like okay i get it it's not
airflow airflow let's build our own
custom solution and let's buy looker so
we bought looker we got rid of chardio
and we were like great
still spending all our time writing sql
queries in these complex ways dealing
with a huge a lot of tables
in a custom tool i know you're all
thinking we're now more modern let's
switch to snowflake and let's use dbt
and looker and get the standard stack
yeah well
now we have way more questions coming in
we're still spending four hours in dbt
building transformations and now we have
liquor which requires even more time for
me to build liquomel
so why the does this keep happening
well here's the real problem every new
question that you get from the business
often requires changes to our
transformation layer and this is where
all the sql lies this is why we have so
many tools to help us understand what's
going on with our data because we have
lineage and all these things because we
have so many queries that we need to
maintain in our middle layer
so
why do data models need this constant
change well
often we think about data model and we
think about people asking these kind of
questions like what's the average
support ticket what percent of tickets
are billing related
these questions are no longer the
questions people are asking because you
can get every single one of these
answers in your zendesk production
dashboard the questions people are
actually asking look a little bit more
like this
are people still submitting tickets
after they view the doc site
okay are people what ticket types lead
to highest churn rate
the problem is that these things relate
different things that don't have a clear
join they don't have a clear foreign key
and star schema wasn't built for
something like this and these are the
questions that people are asking if you
worked in data analysis you've gotten
hundreds and hundreds of questions about
these kind of questions
so the real problem
here's the thing every question that
requires a unique combination of data
so often what we've been thinking is
that the problem has been bi tools
relating data when the real problem has
always been how the hell do i join this
data and all we've done really good is
we've developed a lot of hacky joins and
sql people use people love saying that
everyone needs to learn sql because like
a product people don't know how to use
where statements and group by no they
can figure that out and there's a
hundred sql semantic products that help
you solve that problem the real problem
is the actual join query to relate
sessions and calls is like 200 lines
so
how do we fix this problem well what if
we can remove all predefined joins from
the data model and be able to relate any
data for any question
how the hell do we remove data so we
invented this thing called the activity
schema it's a single table approach to
all of data analytics it's one table and
you can take all your raw data from all
your source tables and kind of
denormalize it to be time customer and
event based so you can write simple
queries and you can put everything you
need to do on top of this one table and
we say customer but we've seen people
use companies properties scooters dogs
all sorts of things as your customer and
we've actually published this thing and
wrote a spec on it which is open source
for
activityschema.com and you can learn
in the in narrator this is really hard
to see you can define different kind of
these events these activities so you can
have your tickets from zendesk your uh
subscriptions from stripe your order
from shopify your leads from salesforce
and all you have to do to define this
simple thing is once you connect to your
data warehouse is just simply write a
tiny sql snippet that maps the raw data
into our standard 10 column structure it
takes 14 minutes on average and it's
around 25 lines
the really interesting thing here is
that you never defined how any of these
activities relate to each other so you
never tell the system how anything
relates to each other so you're always
there's no predefined joints here so a
good example that i like to often use
is what happens if you're trying to
relate email data to order
so when you think about emails and order
data like this specific email did this
lead to an order you often think about
did that email get clicked did that
click have a utm parameters that utm
parameter get copied on the website and
that youtube parameters goes on the
order so in narrator i can literally
just come in and say give me every
opened email
and give me this thing called first in
between
uh completed order by using customer and
time we can actually create any
relationship that you need so in
narrator we're going to grab a single
user look at their entire journey the
way that we would debug it naturally and
for every email we're going to see in
between those emails give me the first
order and we're going to drag all the
data from that activity into the table
second one drag it third one there's
nothing let's put no
and it turns out every question you have
can be answered using just
these
11 operators and your activities and
what narrator is going to do is
instantly use that single table like
that one table that we just built
activity stream and generate the data
you need and because the data is now
pivoted you can actually
think of you can start using data for
analysis you can do anything you want
even cooler if i scroll down to find a
user who's already kind of converted you
can even right-click because of this
single table and see everything in that
table so across your entire data
warehouse i can see every action the
customer has taken from your internal
database to your zendesk to your sales
force across all your systems
but we could take this even further
because the point of narrator is that um
when you have standardization you can
really start reusing data and building
something even more if every company in
the world that today uses narrator has
the exact same 10 column table then we
can actually reuse analyses and
algorithms and in this case we're using
one of our generic analyses to do how
does campaign type impact the conversion
rate to an order and it's
super simple you just simply
use that single table approach which is
in one of our templates and you can hit
run analysis and narrator is able to do
something that you kind of hoped for we
standardized data so now we can share
analyses and right now live is actually
processing this data on the warehouse
running all these queries data never
leaves your system and it's able to
generate a full story that is in human
text that starts with a real question
tells you if it's actionable makes clear
recommendation and uh gives you the
actual lift not only does it give you
the output it can actually walk you
through everything it's doing and all
the tables it generated and all the
interpretations they made
to make these decisions from applying
dimensional reduction to consistency to
significance to a whole lot more things
to the final lift this whole thing
happened without a single predefined
join and this entire process you can see
me do on any question you have if you've
seen me do this demo before or any demo
i'll be here outside afterward and you
can come up with any question you have
and i can show you how that question can
be answered on our standard data
structure super fast super easily all in
under five minutes without ever having a
data analyst pre-define a single join
thank you guys i'm ahmed and i look
forward to talking to
[Applause]